Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest
developer news from Google.
Make sure not to miss a
single episode by subscribing
to this channel right now.
Done?
OK, good.
It's been a couple
weeks since Google I/O,
and there's a few updates
that you might have missed.
Here they are.
SyntaxNet, the world's
most accurate parser,
is now open source.
It's a neural network framework
implemented in TensorFlow
that provides a foundation for
natural language understanding
systems.
The release includes
all the code
needed to train new
models on your own data
as well as Parsey McParseface,
a parser already trained
to analyze English text.
Actually, it's the most accurate
model of its kind in the world.
Visit the post for more
information and the GitHub
link.
Make big, unusual, and
interactive displays controlled
through a web page using the
newly open source library
AnyPixel.js.
The Google Creative Lab
built it for a really cool
interactive display made from
6,000 light-up arcade buttons
acting as interactive pixels.
Check out the video
and grab the code
from the post, linked below.
Project Tango has a
new tutorial project
that enables you to
place virtual cats
in your augmented
reality environment.
It's got a simple
interface and, well, cats.
Lots and lots of cats.
In Daydream Labs,
the Google VR team
is exploring the possibilities
of virtual reality
and sharing what they
learned with the world.
In this recent post, they
describe one of their app
experiments, a keyboard made
out of tiny virtual drums
that works really well.
Check it out.
The Mobile Ads Garage
is a new series
that covers how to use the
Mobile Ads SDK to display ads
from AdMob and DoubleClick
for Publishers.
Check out the series
and the newest episode
now available with a
detailed explanation
of the interstitial ad
lifecycle, how to load ads,
and how to display at
just the right time.
Every year, there are
trillions of searches on Google
and over half of those
searches happen on mobile.
And across the
millions of websites
using Google Analytics today,
we're seeing more than half
of all web traffic now coming
from smartphones and tablets.
To help marketers succeed
in this mobile-first world,
we have redesigned AdWords from
the ground up and rethought
everything from
creatives and bidding,
to workflow and measurement.
Check out the post
for highlights
of recent announcements and
links to learn even more.
And if you haven't already,
now is a great time
to subscribe to
this channel so you
don't miss a single episode
of What's New and Awesome.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.